we're gonna begin with this a CDC
investigation revealing new information
about the explosive coronavirus outbreak
at several Washington State nursing
homes the probe says it was fueled by
missteps including six staff members 35
fatalities are linked to the life care
center in Kirkland that is the hardest
hit facility and Arthur our Jonathan
Vigliotti shows us what investigators
have found among the key findings some
of life care staff worked while sick and
in some cases worked a second shift and
other facilities raising concern that
the virus was spread from one nursing
home to another already in King County
at least 10 nursing homes are reporting
cases of the corona virus a newly
released CDC report is shedding light on
how the corona virus spread at the Life
Care Center in Kirkland Washington and
other area nursing facilities the agency
says of the roughly 130 residents at
life care
62% became infected and 27% have died we
first met Carmen gray earlier this month
they're being held hostage in a petri
dish
her mother Susan Haley is one of the
life care residents who tested positive
I'm in shock this report is it's
despicable
according to the report in mid-february
several residents developed respiratory
illnesses but tested negative for
influenza
it wasn't until roughly two weeks later
February 28th that health officials
confirmed the first case of corona virus
Timothy Killian is a spokesman for the
life care center have we gotten those
tests earlier all of this might have
played out differently but the CDC says
several other factors at the nursing
homes also contributed to the spread
including staff members who worked while
symptomatic and worked in more than one
facility inadequate supplies including
personal protective equipment and hand
sanitizer and limited testing both my
sister and I had concerns about the lack
of use of hand sanitizer and only having
masks on and wearing the same masks in
and out of one room to another are there
things within the report that are
troubling to all of us of course there
was questions about proper infection can
trol this disease this virus requires
measures different than anything else we
dealt with before at least 34 life care
center employees and 14 visitors also
contracted the virus I hope that they
find this is an example of what not to
do if you listen to the doctors they're
saying that it's going to get much worse
before it gets better and the CDC report
doesn't mention their own shortcoming
with delay testing nor does it mention
the initial response by Washington state
health officials who just four days into
the outbreak said their resources were
stretched then Jonathan thank you and
our doctor Tara Narula is back with more
on this we heard one of the relatives
say that their family members were held
hostage in a petri dish it's a terrible
situation what are the lessons here yeah
I mean it kind of is the perfect storm
these are people that are in very close
contact the median age is 81 we know the
death rate goes up if you're over 80 and
a lot of them have these chronic medical
conditions like hypertension
cardiovascular disease kidney disease
diabetes so it's a tough situation and
it really tells us we need to be
proactive and I know we are taking those
steps now we've seen family members who
can't visit their loved ones in nursing
homes it's very painful for them but
it's important for them to stay away it
is we know that most of these cases
happen from either a visitor or staff
member bringing the infection in there
so it is hard to stay away it's very
difficult but it's very important
yeah I'm still stuck by that petri dish
reference it's like that they were
sitting ducks in some way can you be
exposed to it Tara and not get it well
you can be exposed to her and not mount
a reaction that somebody can pick up on
so it could be either asymptomatic or
mildly symptomatic so a lot of this is
about active screening for fever or
respiratory symptoms and staff and
patients so that you can act quickly and
is it important to point out that most
people depending on your age you it's
very survivable it is people need to
understand you can survive this you can
those people do most people do but again
those vulnerable populations the elderly
those with chronic medical conditions
are more at risk of having severe
complications all right Tara thank you
very much